[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بين تحرير من
فوضى مقبله وتبشير بربيع مزهر جارات
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في تركيا
مستقبلان محتملان امام المجتمع التركيه
الذي يوصف بانه منقسمه بشده بين
المتنافسين الابرزين رجب طيب اردوغان
وكمال اوغلو الانتخابات التركيه تترافق
بين طرفين لهما رؤى متناقضه اردوغان يحذر
انصاره من احتمال دفع ما وصفه بثمن الباهز
اذا تمكن منافسه العلماني كما وصفه من
الفوز فيما تعهد منافسه كلتشدار اوغلو
باجراء قطيعه مع ارث اردوغان اذا فاز
بالانتخابات كلتشدار اوغلو طرح نفسه
كمحارب ضد الفساد المستشري منذ سنوات
والمحسوبيه التي وصلت بحسب قوله الى اعلى
هرم الدوله وفي مقدمه تعهدات كذلك تحدث
اردوغان على احترام دوله القانون
والمؤسسات التي تضررت بمي او كلتش دار
اوغلو تحدث عن ذلك والتي تضررت بميول
اردوغان الاستبداديه كما وصفها كما تعهد
بالعوده الى الديمقراطيه البرلمانيه
وباحداث تحول كبير في السياسه الخارجيه
لتركيا اما اردوغان فيستند على انجازاته
التي يصفها بالعظيمه والتي ادت الى تحديث
تركيا مجددا الحديث عن نجاحاته بالازدهار
وبالاقتصاد فضلا عن اتهامته للمعارضه
بانها تتلقى اوامر من الغرب وان ممثليها
سيخضعون لرغبات الدول الغربيه اذا تم
انتخابهم دائما بحسب كلام اردوغان
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
نناقش كل هذا مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول زاهد
رئيس تحرير تركيا اهلا بك من اسطنبول كذلك
طه عوده اوغلو الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام سابدا معك استاذ
زاهد استاذ زاهد قبل الدخول الى تفاصيل
الارقام والاعداد ونحن نشير الى ان
اردوغان حتى الان
تقدم على منافسه كلتشدار اوغلو بنسبه
52.12 فقط نحدث قليلا لانه الارقام
52.03 الان ستبقى العين على هذه النسب
ولكن سيد زاهد لماذا تعتبر هذه الانتخابات
انتخابات مفصليه انتخابات استثنائيه ويقول
البعض بانها قادره حتى على ان تغير وجه
تركيا السياسي اذا اردنا ان نجيب على هذا
السؤال بطريقه واضحه صريحه وبسيطه ماذا
نقول
ابتداء وانتهاء هذه نعم انتخابات ابتداء
وانتهاء لكنها تاتي في اطار او بمعنى
الاستفتاء على اولا النظام السياسي التركي
القائم بمعنى اننا نعلم انه منذ خمس سنوات
النظام المعمول به في تركيا هو النظام
الرئاسي
ووعد المعارضه انها تتحول الى النظام
البرلماني باسباب موضوعيه بحسب رايها
وبحسب طرحها والاشكاليات التي نتج عن
تطبيقات النظام الرئاسي وبالتالي فوز
المعارضه تعني بالضروره ضروره ان النظام
الرئاسي لم يعد صالحا لتركيا وضروره
الانتقال الى النظام البرلماني لان الشارع
التركي يرغب بهذا الامر بحسب هذا المفهوم
وبالتالي من المؤكد ان وجه تركيا سيتغير
فيه الشيء الامر الاخر وبشكل سريع ايضا
استطيع ان اؤكد ان المهله الدستوريه
والقانونيه للرئيس عندما تنتهي بعد ايام
قبل ان يجدد له او قبل ان ينتصر معارضه
تنتهي معه ولايه اكثر من او قريب من 1500
موظف حكومي من الدرجات العليا يعني ابتداء
من رئيس المخابرات مرورا بسفراء الدول
مرورا بالكثير من القطاعات الحيويه داخل
الدوله وبالتالي هؤلاء اما ان يتم تعيينهم
مره اخرى بقرار رئاسي او ان اخرين سيحلون
محلها هؤلاء لان ولايتهم ايضا تنتهي حسب
النظام الرئاسي مع انتهاء رئاسه الرئيس
وبالتالي لا شك اننا اذا افترضنا ان فوز
المعارضه وشيك او انه سيحدث هذا يعني ان
تغيرا في قياده مؤسسات الدوله
وتمثيلها في الخارج سيقع بالفعل خلال
الايام القادمه وبالتالي لا شك انه
بالنسبه لتركيا تغير كبير سيقع خلال هذه
الفتره
من حضرتك
باختصار انت كرمت تفضل
باختصار شديد يعني حسب المعطيات ايضا
الراهنه حسب الارقام الاوليه بطبيعه الحال
والتي اعتقد انها ستتغير خلال ساعتين هناك
تقدم ملحوظ للمعارضه في البرلمان وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث اذا فاز اردوغان عن انه سيكون
بدا ذراع برلماني يعني بمعنى انه سيحتاج
الى خطاب جديد والى تحالفات جديده
تحديثات النساء
وعمليه الفرز الاوليه ارى بان حزب العداله
والتنميه متفوق حتى الان بنسبه اتحدث في
البرلمان بنسبه 56%
تقول بانه قد
ارقامك ارقامك من وكاله الاناضول ارقامك
سيدتي من وكاله
الاناضول لا تعرض حتى على وكالات اخرى
تعرضها حتى صيانه مثلا وكاله الاناضول
معطياتها وارقامها مختلفه على سبيل المثال
لكن هذا الخلاف انا لا اعتقد ان هناك
خلافا جوهريا حقيقيا في هذا الموضوع وان
الارقام والنسب تتضح خلال ساعتين الاكيد
باننا سنبقى في متابعه وانتظار كذلك
الاعلان النهائي والرسمي ولكنك تحدثت عن
نقطه ملفته استاذ زاهه تقول بانه موضوع
نظام برلماني والنظام رئاسي ليس هو الاهم
هناك كذلك مواضيع اخرى على نفس القدر من
الاهميه تحدثت مثلا عن التمثيليه
الدبلوماسيه وهنا سؤال استاذه طه هل
انتخاب رئيس جديد سيغير من التمثيليه
الدبلوماسيه وبالتالي قادر ان يغير كذلك
من مواقف تركيا وتعاملها مع مختلف الملفات
التي تعنينا في المنطقه وفي العالم
تحياتي للجميع في البدايه من دون سكن
اعتقد في حال وصل السيد كمال الى السلطه
سوف تكون هناك السياسه مختلفه تماما ان
كانت على الصعيد الخارجي وهذا ما لمح اليه
خلال الفتره الماضيه وخاصه في ما يتعلق
بموضوع
يعني تعامله مع الدول الاقليميه ودول
العربيه وانها سوف يكون هو متجه نحو الشرق
عفوا نحو الغرب ولكن كما تعلمين كما تشاهد
هو تحدث خلال الفتره الاخيره الماضيه عن
وعود كبيره وهي وعود اقتصاديه لذا
يفهم الكلام وبناءه سوف يركز في الفتره
الاولى في حال فاز في الانتخابات على داخل
التركي وعلى الاقتصاد التركي لذا سوف يكون
بعيد كل البعد عن القضايا التي كان التي
كانت منخرطه فيها مثلا موضوع الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه مواضيع يعني هامه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وهذا كما يعني اشرت لك
سوف نلاحظ ان هناك تغيير بشكل كامل في
السياسه الخارجيه التركيه وكان هناك ايضا
يعني انتقادات كبيره يعني من قبل السيد
كما لسياسه اردوغان في السابق فيما يتعمل
فيما يتعلق بعلاقاته مع مصر سابقا وفي
علاقاتهم مع سوريا نعم حاليا الوضع تحسن
وتغير خلال تقريبا عام او عام ونصف من
الان بعد السياسه التصالحيه التي انتهجها
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان خلال الفتره
الماضيه لذا انا اتصور اعتقد اليوم
الناخبه تركي هو صوت اما الاستمرار مع
اردوغان لفتره اخرى او لتركيا العلمانيه
التي يعني اسسها مصطفى كمال اتاتورك وهناك
وجه مختلف وجه جديد وهنا اقصد في السيد
كمال
هو الذي هو وعد يعني نعم المواطنين في
الدرجه الاولى فيما يتعلق بالوضع
الاقتصادي كما تعلمين الوضع الاقتصادي هو
كان العنوان الابرز في كافه الحملات
الانتخابيه وهو الذي كما تعلمين ايضا
عندما وصل الرئيس اردوغان الى السلطه في
عام 2002 هو دخل من بوابه الاقتصاد بعدما
كانت حكومه بلنت اجاويد مفلسه وطاحت بها
الازمه الاقتصاديه جاء اردوغان حاليا هو
يراهن ويعول على هذه النقطه من خلال بوابه
الاقتصاد والازمه الاقتصاديه والسخط لدى
شريحه كبيره من الشباب وشريحه المترددين
ايضا
بالعوده قليلا الى داخل التركي معك استاذ
زاهد اردوغان يروج لفكره
تقديمه
لتطور عظيم قدمه لتركيا طيله 20 سنه من
حياته السياسيه هناك حديث عن مجال الطاقه
هناك حديث عن الغاز الطبيعي وحقول النفط
هناك حديث عن محطه نوويه تركيه حديث عن
اول سياره كهربائيه عن البنيه التحتيه
هناك حديث عن في سنوات الاولى عن تراجع
نسبه التضخم كل هذا يقول انصار اردوغان
بانه انفاس فستكون هذه العوامل هي التي
حفظت الناخب ليصوت له هل تعتقد بانه هذا
سيفسد على المعارضه كل هذا
سيفشل المعارضه
يعني ابتداء وانتهاء كما تفضلتي جزء كبير
من هذه الانجازات قد قدمت للشارع التركي
والشعب التركي خلال 15 عاما او عشرين عاما
ماضيه لكن منذ خمس سنوات تحديدا لا يمكن
الحديث عن انجازات كبيره كما كان يحدث في
السابق بمعنى ان السيد اردوغان هذه ربما
اول انتخابات يدخلها وقد تضائل
ونزل القوم الدخل القومي للفرد التركي
يعني في السابق كان هناك مقارنات ماذا
انجز اردوغان خلال خمس سنوات للمواطن
التركي وكان المواطن التركي في الاطار
العام يشعر براحه اقتصاديه لكن هذه
الانتخابات الاولى التي يعاني منها الشارع
التركي عموما من ازمه اقتصاديه لا زالت
مستمره منذ قرابه الثلاث سنوات نحن نتحدث
ان القيمه قيمه الليره التركيه
من قيمتها قرابه السبعين بالمئه فقط خلال
الفتره الوجيزه الماضيه وبالتالي التغيرات
التي حزب حدثت في البعد الاقتصادي هي
كبيره جدا الامر الاخر الزلزال واداره هذا
الملف من قبل الحكومه ايضا كان مثار
استياء الى درجه ان السيد اردوغان تقبل
عمليا انه في بعض المدن على سبيل المثال
اضيما كان هناك تقصير من قبل مؤسسات
الدوله ولجا قبل ايام الى اقاله او اجبر
رئيس الهلال الاحمر بتقديم استقالته وقال
ان التصرفاته ببيع الخيم التي هي يجب ان
تقدم كمساعدات امر مرفوض نعم مثل هذه
التصرفات قد وقعت ايضا اداره ازمه كورونا
خلال الخمس سنوات الماضيه
شابه الشيء الكثير من الانتقادات اذا هناك
عمليا في الواقع مت حقيقيه الامر الاخير
بطبيعه الحال المعارضه خلال ال15 سنه
الماضيه ايضا كانت مشرذمه مبعثره مشتته
كان هناك اكثر من حزب واكثر من مرشح لكل
حزب وبالتالي التنافس لم يكن مع فرد واحد
وشخص واحد وجبهه واحده كما هو الواقع
فعليا الان وبالتالي لاول مره المعارضه
لديها دعني اقول ايضا في المقابل برنامج
المعارضه لديها رؤى وعود بل واسماء قدمتها
لاصلاح الخلل الاقتصادي واصلاح الخلل فيما
يتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه واصلاح الخلل
فيما يتعلق بالعمليه التعليميه اذا هناك
رؤيه لاول مره بغض النظر هل هي قابله
للتطبيق هل ستطبق ام لا هذا نقاش اخر لكن
المعارضه اعتقد انه كان مختلفا عما كان
سابقا انا المعارضه معروفه كمعارضه ولانها
ولكنها لم يتم اختبارها في الحكم كذلك
بان الحكم قد يختلف عن المعارضه ولكن
استاذ طه في هذا الاطار هل يمكن ان تفوز
المعارضه على ما اعتمدت عليه من اسماء
قدمت من وعود كذلك من تفاصيل لبرنامجها
الانتخابي ام ان ارث اردوغان سيتذكره
البعض وسيحفظ البعض للتصويت له وبالتالي
سيرجح كافه التقليدي يعني
يجب ان نعترف ان هناك حقيقه هناك حاله من
الغضب والسخط لدى الشارع التركي خلال
الفتره الاخيره الماضيه لدى سياسه حزب
العداله والتنميه واقول حزب العداله
والتنميه الحزب الحاكم وليس الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان تلاحظين ان شعبيه اردوغان لم
تتغير ما زال هو الرجل الاقوى داخل تركيا
وشاهدنا قبل اسبوع او اسبوعين الان التجمع
الاحتفال الذي عقده هنا في مدينه اسطنبول
مليون و700 الف شخص حتى ان بي بي سي
البريطانيه تحدثت يعني كيف زعيم ان يجمع
هذا العدد بعد عقدين من الزمن ولكن تحدثين
عن المعارضه نتصور المعارضه اعتقد هي امام
فرصه يعني كبيره وهذه الفرصه خاصه يعني
تجمعت العديد من العوامل ان كانت جائحه
كورونا
الازمه الاقتصاديه اذا لم تستطع يعني
ازاحه اردوغان هذه المره انا اتصور اعتقد
سوف تكون النهايات لزعماء على سبيل مساك
كما على سبيل المثال احمد داوود اول الذي
هو يحول بشكل كبير على ان يكون بديل لما
بعد اردوغان وليس حاليا او كما ايضا علي
بابا جان لذا هذه الزعامات وهذه القيادات
سوف تكون هي يعني تندثر كما تابعنا قبل
عقدين او ثلاث عقود من الان عندما
اسس حزب الوطن الام بزعامه توركوت اوزال
بعد غياب هذا الزعيم اختفى حزب الوطن الام
لذا انا التصوري اعتقد يعني كذا الطرفين
يعني الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان حاليا نعم
هناك حاله من الترهل لازم نعترف في حزب
العداله والتنميه وايضا هناك بعض الاخطاء
ارتكبت من قبل الرئيس اردوغان لكن الى حتى
هذه اللحظه هناك تفكير لدى الشارع التركي
في ظل الاوطان التي تمر فيها المنطقه
وتركيا فيما يتعلق بالاستمرار مع الرئيس
لمده خمس سنوات خاصه
خاصه الانسب وخاصه انه هو يعني سوف تكون
نعم اعطني مقاطعه سنعود كذلك للحديث عن
نقاط صله تفضلوا بالبقاء معي استاذ زاهد
واستاذ طه كذلك نذهب الى هذا الفاصل ومن
ثم نعود
[موسيقى]
ونتوقف مع فاصل مشاهدينا من بعد سنعود
لنتابع دائما في هذا النقاش
اهتمام اقلمي ودولي بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه التركيه كيف ستبدو العلاقات
التركيه الدوليه في العهد الرئاسي الجديد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات